- Quel est votre état civil
actuellement?
- Conjoint de fait.
- Célibataire.
- Je suis marié.
- Conjoint de fait.
- Célibataire.
- Le trois quarts des couples
sont mariés au pays.
Mais le nombre de couples
en union libre augmente.
Le Canada arrive au prrrr
rang pour ce type d'union
parmi les pays du G7.
Est-ce que vous comptez un jour
vous marier ou pas du tout?
- Euh... probablement.
- Aucune idée.
- Je vois pas la nécessité.
- C'est au Québec, au Nunavut
et dans les territoires du Nord-
Ouest que la proportion
de couples en union libre
est plus élevée.
Autre constat : le nombre
de couples ayant au moins
un enfant a diminué.
Il y a 50 ans, il était de 64 %.
Il est aujourd'hui de 50 %.
CÉLINE LE BOURDAIS, titu.,
Chaire rech. stats. sociales, Ca
- Le recensement, c'est juste
comme une photo instantanée.
Il y a des couples là-dedans qui
sont encore jeunes, qui n'ont
pacococore eu le temps d'avoir
leurs enfants. Et d'un autre
côté, il y a des couples âgés
dont les enfants sont déjà
partis.
- Et pour rereremière fois,
Statistique Canada comptabilise
les données sur la diversité
de gs.s.s. 1,5 % des couples
sont de même genre ou comptent
une personne transgenre ou
non binaire.
Pour ce qui est des revenus
des Canadiens : ils sont
en hausse partout au pays
à l'exception des provinces
de Terre-Neuve-et-Labrador
et de l'Alberta. À Montréal,
le revenu médian des ménages
après impôts est de 65 500 $.
De 85 000 $ à Toronto, et
de 87 000 $ à Calgary.
Parmi les dix plus grands
centres urbains du Canada,
les villes de Québec et
de Montréat t t les revenus
médians les plus bas.
MATHURIN JEANNOT MANCABO, Centre
statistique revenu, Stat. Ca
- Les revenus médians du Québec
sont un petit peu supérieurs
à ce qu'on constate dans
les provinces de l'Atlantique.
Mais, elles sont inférieures,
par exemple, au revenu médian
en Ontario, en Alberta.
- L'aide financière
durant la pandémie a aussi eu
des impacts sur les inégalités
financières. Le nombre
de ménages à faible revenu
avait diminué en 2020.
Ici Marie-Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréa